[Music]
I'm often asked this question of what
advice would I give to an aspiring
actress or actor the thing I do find
myself saying often is you should just
don't ever give up if acting is
something that you feel is in your veins
and in your DNA and and you just want to
do it and believe that you should and
believe that you can then if you keep
believing that enough and you keep
working hard because it's not going to
be handed you want to plate then that's
more important than anything else
determination and confidence will get
you everywhere especially when you walk
into an audition room because if you
walk into an audition room and you're
terrified and desperate then they'll
smell it on you and you're less likely
to get the job if you just believe in
yourself and you work hard and you walk
in there and bring confidence and good
positive energy with you you're much
more likely to get another looking I
live my life you know and every time I'm
cast in a film I am equally as terrified
as I was about the challenge when I did
my first film in seventeen and when I
did Titanic and when I did it turn on
sometime of the spotless mind and when I
did the reader you know that fear I
think is what drives me to be honest you
know acting it's such a wonderful thing
to do and I I I love it and I and I love
it more as I'm getting older I think but
it is scary because you can easily get
it wrong
five key traits to be successful I don't
know if I've really got five I mean I
think I would certainly say one of them
would be you know to work hard you know
because I do think that we live in a
time now where it's quite easy to get a
sort of full sense of celebrity or fame
and to aspire towards celebrity and fame
without even taking into account the
steps that you need to take to get to
achieve that thing I think it's making
young people lose that sense of work
ethic you know if you believe that
there's something you want to do and you
want to be successful at it it will not
just come to you you have to work
towards achieving that goal you know no
one else is going to achieve it for you
it's you've only got yourself to rely on
and I would say so self reliance really
determination confidence positivity and
staying healthy you know I think healthy
in your mind and in your body especially
at this time that we live in now where I
think there is a lot of pressure there's
a lot of exposure I think it's difficult
to be private for young people who
aren't even in the public eye just
children who are at school and hang on
to that sense of privacy because once
you give it away it's very very hard to
get back and just self-respect
I think those things are important
[Music]